[Musique]
au luxembourg où lycéens et lycéennes
jouent déjà aux étudiants on discute des
récentes mesures prises par certains
proviseurs qui interdisent de porter les
pantalons des jupes ont large des
talents au de se maquiller de se coiffer
en hauteur et pour les garçons de porter
les cols roulés des blue jeans et des
blousons noirs que pensent les
intéressés les rapports de la mode et
des travaux scolaires
alors oui mais l'ennui qui se
singularise et une mauvaise élève non
pas spécialement mais en général les
corps arrivent en retard quand elles
sont maquillés parce que ça leur fera
une heure elles ont de mauvaises notes
mais ça leur est égal ou rsa est ce
qu'il ya des glaces annonces n'ont
aucune place dans le lycée c'est que
vous savez il ya des portes vitrées
alors une élève se met derrière est
alors dans l'ombre les autres personnes
gardées face au système glace s'est
certes pas très bon mais ces systèmes
qu'on emploie le blue jeans
pourquoi le lathan interdit le guzheng
parce que le budget ne trouve tous les
films nouvelle vague avait avec des
acteurs avec des blue-jeans alors les
proviseurs les directeurs de lycées ont
eu peur que la nouvelle vague
s'installant les études les est une
nouvelle vague c'était pas très très
agréable pour eux parce qu'il fallait
tout changer plusieurs passages en soit
mise à me classer 6ème tout ce qui est
très classique que les garçons sont
aussi qu'avec les filles coq et non mais
enfin eux aussi sont obligés de suivre
des modes
par exemple lorsque 6e 6e demain 26
demain dans une serre où ce parti et
d'un garçon qui sera menée avec la raie
au milieu un geek et leur offrir cette
odyssée irait pas du tout alors ici de
la mode à une ruche veut très court
cette année ses cheveux plus longs
il ya cette année c'est la mode de la
can si les garçons portent une canne
serrée entre les deux doigts très
agréable il aime beaucoup ça qui aussi
les lunettes les garçons aiment beaucoup
les lunettes même si son album dingue
c'est extrêmement snob tout ça au vu du
très snob pour très précis mais il ya
aussi d'autres modes qui sont très
éloignées de la tenue vestimentaire il
ya je crois une mode des lunettes chez à
oui ça fait très chic d'avoir des
lunettes
avec des bots bord cela dépend aussi des
filles et puis on a aussi beaucoup la
mode et parapluies en cette année de la
mode des bottes tu t'en sors très
pratique parce que vous pouvez les
mettre aussi bien avec un pantalon
qu'avec eux pendant que durant la pluie
je ne sais pas c'est très pratique et
l'année dernière et l'année dernière
c'était des petites chaussures très fine
ouïe très fine oui alors c'est à dire
que l'année dernière vous aviez bien
froid répit cette année vous aurez bien
joué ici t'es pas du tout pratique parce
que moi je vais dans un lycée où il ya
beaucoup de cailloux et elle devrait pas
longtemps ils vont professeur que penser
de la mode on se dépense cette année
sans plus tôt sur gentil mais là je me
rappelle j'avais une directrice surtout
qui nous faisait monter sur l'estrade et
avec une règle venez mesure est
minutieusement la longueur de nos genoux
et de la jupe ou les joues à par terre
qu'ils aient la longueur réglementaire
enfin c'est assez lent violence du jeu
le vent rivel au dessus du genou oui ils
ont tous pas de jupe ans parce qu'on
pouvait parler aux cuisses alors quel
est votre avis sur la mode adopté par
vos camarades filles quand c'est une
bonne réellement féminines c'est aussi
très agréable à voir parce que les modes
féminine se succèdent à un rythme
tellement fou que l'on quitte quelqu'un
jour biais d'une manière lendemain matin
on rentre complètement changé et qu'elle
est la tenue idéale pour sortir avec une
jeune fille moi je crois comme ça je
crois que la plupart des garçons
préfèrent les sifi et non pas les filles
femmes c'est quand il voit une jeune
fille qui essaye de se lier par tous les
moyens et qu'il essaye d'avoir la moitié
du physique femmes et la moitié du
public filles c'est assez désagréable
est ce que vous prenez vos impératifs de
mode chez deux vedettes pas toujours
il arrive que par exemple les yeux c'est
bien de voler parcours en particulier et
il ya beaucoup de déguisements des cieux
parce que tout ça fait un regard plus
pénétrants curieux il pour séduire les
garçons j'imagine oui à genève art et
bien mais en quoi elle il ya des
compétitions est pour vous une fille qui
se singularise est une mauvaise élève
peut-être une bonne élève aux mauvais
élèves pas toujours mais on souvent
comme il fixe aussi qu'à lui et
singularise c'est qu'elle ne sait quel
point c'est autre chose on s'accroche on
y at il des règlements a écrit et porter
à votre connaissance dans les lycées sur
le port de certaines parties de piment
oui un règlement très précis je suis au
lycée molière et à partir de zéro degré
on a le droit de porter des pantalons
mais des pantalons de certaines couleurs
bleu marine gris anthracite et pas notre
club est en dessous de zéro degré
pourquoi monsieur la carte directeur de
cette école at il été amené à rendre
obligatoire le port de la blouse et
pourquoi lui at il cru nécessaire
d'intervenir dans la tenue de ses élèves
depuis quelle date l'école alsacienne
que vous dirigez monsieur le directeur
est elle fondée depuis 1914 elle a été
fondée par d'anciens résistants y
avait-il à ce moment là une recherche
dans la façon dont on s'habille et les
élèves je crois pas ce type oblats n'y a
pas tellement recherche les jeunes
s'habiller comme les adultes
j'ai ici une photographie de 1880 où
l'on voir des élèves et des professeurs
il est même mal aisé de reconnaître
qu'ils élèves et les professeurs les
deux personnages qui se trouvent ici à
gauche sans les élèves
il porte le blanc la seule différence
côte est c'est que les professeurs sont
barbu et porte le chapeau haut de forme
est-ce qu'ils ont jamais ressembler des
enfants les élèves de l'école bien j'ai
ici également une photographie de 1928
nous avons des filles à l'école est
dotée depuis 1906 disent à peu près vous
pouvez voir que les professeurs ont
toujours la varde le canotier à
remplacer le chapeau de forme
quant aux jeunes gens et jeunes filles
eh bien disons plutôt la lure de scouts
d'éclairer voici une autre photographie
qui datent de 1945
et là il est extrêmement significatif de
voir les jeunes filles la classe de
première
s'en va avec des chaussures de cuir
extrêmement simples chaussures de sport
et bien désormais à peu près comme ils
sont habillés en ce moment après commune
rhabiller chez nous en ce moment
et à partir de quand leur nom s'il plus
ressembler à nouveau des enfants
je vois que dix ans après 1945 1955
on a commencé à voir habitations de
l'amérique certainement une
recrudescence de costumes extrêmement
disparates qui n'avait plus rien à voir
avec un costume d'enfants donnant à
l'école alors qu'elle vous interdit aux
navires c'est beaucoup dire
nous avons essayé de promouvoir non pas
parce que les interdictions sont
toujours des choses un peu facho nous
avons demandé aux élèves de venir un peu
plus fonctionner qu'est-ce qu'on vous
interdis nous interdit les cheveux dans
le dos des cheveux décolorés le
maquillage les lunettes fumées
le sac à main
les pantalons les collants de couleurs
le terreau pensez vous que votre
directeur a eu raison
interdire les chandails et col roulé non
parce que le col le col roulé sert à
tenir chaud et là il est bon l'hiver et
il en le col roulé avec le pull-over
empêche de prendre le blazer ou la veste
élégante qui même à travers un tablier
se salit les blue jeans
oui parce que ça fait mauvais genre les
chaussures de basket et il a bien eu
raison parce que les chaussures de
basket sont les pieds plats n'échouer
trop long pour les garçons ça fait aussi
mauvais genre et ça fait sale vous
oblige à porter une blouse jusqu'à
quelle classe toutes les classes sont
obligés de porter des blouses
mais mieux vaut même le mignan pourquoi
portez-vous part je suis contre la
blouse je trouve que la blouse détruit
toute personnalité puis enfin quand on
voit dans la course a fait uniforme un
peu moi je suis contre la boue ça me
plaît pas mais évidemment je suis obligé
de l'admettre je la mets dans les cours
mais dès que je peux m'en débarrasser je
l'enlève
vous avez l'impression que vous
travailler mieux moins bien avec une
blouse bon je suis la même chose mais
enfin je suis pas comme lorsque j'ai une
blouse ben je me sens un peu un peu
diminué mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
considère comme un petit garçon de 5 ans
n'est pas ma blouse
ça fait plus étudiant chez pas simple je
préfère ne pas savoir blues plus de ça
vous rajeunit un peu trop d'avoir une
blouse ce sera oui c'était une blouse
qui ne me paraît pas bien propre et
effectivement elle était assez sale
depuis combien de temps ne l'avez-vous
pas lavez-vous fait laver
depuis à peu près six mois c'est moi
mais à l'école la mode est d'avoir une
douce
pourquoi c'est une mode comme ça par
exemple ancien camarade s'ennuie dans un
courrier vous dessinerez blues quand dd
ça lorsque sait plus très bien quoi
faire on met des couleurs sur la base du
camarade d'achat chez monsieur pourquoi
portez-vous une blouse aussi strictes
puisque agir est réduit en meeting et
alors vous pensez que dès maintenant
vous devez en avoir la ville si je puis
dire tout haut moi ça me
oui je sais vous met dans la peau du
personnage
thomas vous avez quel âge chaque jour et
nuit et vous aurez fini votre médecine à
quel âge je sais pas sa défense
ça vous fait mal cette blouse pendant
quelques années encore ah oui et vous
monsieur à quoi vous destinez vous une
carrière scientifique et estimé que le
port de la blouse blanche est
obligatoire dès maintenant
oh oui donc pour un étudiant
scientifique un élève qui a étudié les
sciences doit porter une blouse blanche
c'est une tradition dans les classes
scientifiques et bien nous voilà édifier
les jeunes de 15 à 18 ans sont sages
pratiques et réfléchie la mode pourvu
qu'elles n'aillent pas dans le sens de
l'exagération intéresse les jeunes sont
les passionnés
n'est ce pas là le signe d'une sagesse
très encourageante
[Musique]